it is time for this week's sin city
chronicles let's start back in 1999.
[Music]
august 28 1999 cher performed at the mgm
grand garden arena cindy lauper was her
opening act and the show was released on
dvd it was a huge success becoming
certified platinum in four countries
[Music]
[Applause]
august 29th is michael jackson's
birthday the king of pop would have been
63 years old on sunday now even though
jackson never performed a solo show in
town he still has many connections to
las vegas he received a key to the city
in 2003 and he eventually leased a home
in the area of rancho and alta the
desert inn opened in 1950 and it closed
its doors on august 28 2000. the hotel
was featured in many films including
ocean's eleven sister act two and rush
hour two the di's most famous guest was
howard hughes who lived in the penthouse
suite for four years
wcw monday nitro was at the mgm grand on
august 23rd 1999 the main event right
there sting versus hulk hogan and the
show ended with a performance from kiss
[Music]
the band they were on hand to debut a
new character called the demon
in 1988 the usa men's basketball team
participated in an eight-game schedule
against a bunch of nba all-stars before
heading off to the olympics in seoul
south korea the players for the nba
teams vary by location we're looking at
a game in charlotte with michael jordan
well the olympic team came to the thomas
and mack on august 27 1988 and the big
name for the nba that night was
boom reggie theis there he is my man and
the nba team by the way rocky your dad
and his fellow nba players they won that
night of course they did oh look at him
go look at him go
he's got skills i love that hi your mom
and dad i know they're watching oh they
love you jc that's your sin city
chronicles for the last week of august
take it away as always all right coming